E
BORDER.
SARA CARTER, THANKS FOR GETTING
US THAT REPORT.
TEXAS GOVERNOR, GREG ABBOTT
ISSUING A DISASTER DECLARATION
AMID THIS OUT-OF-CONTROL BORDER
CRISIS.
IT ALLOWS THE USE OF ALL
AVAILABLE STATE RESOURCES TO
ASSIST LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
PROTECTING TEXANS FROM CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY, PROPERTY DAMAGE WHILE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING NOTHING TO PROTECT TEXANS
FROM THIS GROWING THREAT.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY EMBEDDING THE
LAWBREAKING.
BUT THE MOB, THE MEDIA, THEY
CONTINUE TO LAUNCH CHEAP SHOT
AFTER CHEAP SHOT AT RED STATE
GOVERNORS.
LOOK AT THIS REPREHENSIBLE LOWER
THIRD, THE MAN OVER AT
PROPAGANDA, READING TEXAS
TWO-STEP DURING A SEGMENT ABOUT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
HE DRIVES US NOW.
BY THE WAY ALSO ENDORSED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR HIS UPCOMING
REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
BY THE Y GOVERNOR, I SECOND
THAT.
IF IT HURTS YOU, TELL ME YOU
DON'T WANT IT.
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN A GREAT
GOVERNOR.
SEAN, THE DEAL ABOUT THAT, SEAN,
IS WE ARE IN A COMPETITION HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES WHERE
GOVERNORS ARE TRYING TO GET YOU
TO COME TO THEIR STATE.
>> Sean: I'M GETTING OUT OF
HERE.
I'M TELLING YOU, I'M LEAVING.
I CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
LISTEN, IT'S REALLY COME DOWN TO
FLORIDA AND TEXAS.
I'M DOWN TO THOSE TWO.
BUT I STRONGLY SUPPORT YOUR
REELECTION, GOVERNOR.
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB FOR THE
PEOPLE OF TEXAS.
I KNOW YOU WILL CONTINUE.
>> LISTEN, I APPRECIATE THE
PRESIDENT'S ENDORSEMENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT, IT WAS MORE
THAN JUST YET, I ENDORSED
GREG ABBOTT.
LOOK AT THE WORDS HE USED IT TO
TALK ABOUT HOW HE IS ENDORSING
ME AND HOW WE PARTNERED TOGETHER
TO SECURE THE BORDER, CREATE SO
MANY JOBS IN TEXAS THAT ARE NOW
BEING CRUSHED BY THE BITE AND
GREEN NEW DISASTER.
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SO
APPRECIATIVE OF TEXAS.
REMEMBER, HE WAS ABLE TO GET
BOTH IN COUNTIES ALONG THE
BORDER THAT OTHER REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES HAD
NEVER BEEN ABLE TO GET.
HE WON COUNTIES ALONG THE BORDER
THAT NO REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE HAD
EVER WON.
IT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO LIVE ON
THE BORDER, HISPANICS WHO LIVE
ON THE BORDER, THEY WANTED TO
HAVE THEIR BORDER SECURITY.
IT'S CONTRARY TO THE DEMOCRATIC
NARRATIVE WHERE THE HISPANICS ON
THE BORDER A MOTHER WON'T OPEN
BORDERS.
THAT'S FALSE.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROVED THAT
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS WHO
LIVED ON THE BORDER, WHO LIVED
IN LAND IN TEXAS AND AMERICA,
THEY WANT A SECURE BORDER.
AND THAT IS WHAT I AM TRYING TO
STEP UP AND ACHIEVE.
>> Sean: WE SHOWED OUR
AUDIENCE THESE VIDEOS.
WE HAVE SHOWN OUR AUDIENCE THE
VIDEOS OF THESE KIDS ON TOP OF
EACH OTHER IN BIDEN'S CAGES THAT
HE'S BUILDING FOR KIDS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
90% OF THE HEROIN IN THIS
COUNTRY AND FATTEN ALL COMES
ACROSS THAT BORDER.
YOUR OWN CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES WAS DENIED ACCESS FROM
DOING ITS JOB.
YOU ARE BEING PREVENTED FROM
UPHOLDING THE LAW AS A GOVERNOR
OF YOUR STATE BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION IS AIDING
AND ABETTING THE LAWBREAKING AND
MAKING IT HARDER FOR DRUG
TRAFFICKERS AND GANGS AND
EVERYONE ELSE TO DO OTHER
NEFARIOUS THINGS ON THE BORDER.
>> AND SOMEONE NOW WE HAVE 34
COUNTIES ON THE BORDER WHO ASKED
ME TO DECLARE THEIR COUNTY A
DISASTER, WHICH I DID.
NORMALLY DISASTER DECLARATIONS
ARE FOR THINGS LIKE HURRICANES.
I DON'T THINK THIS HAS EVER
HAPPENED BEFORE WHERE A DISASTER
DECLARATION WAS MADE FOR BORDER
COUNTIES BECAUSE OF THE INFLUX
OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
BUT I DID BECAUSE WE ARE ABOUT
TO CHANGE THE WAY THAT TEXAS
ADDRESSES THE CHALLENGES ON THE
BORDER AND WE ARE GOING TO START
BY HELPING THESE 34 COUNTIES
RESPOND BY INCREASING ARRESTS.
WE'VE GOT A NEW GAME IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
>> Sean: WHY CAN'T YOU JUST
SAY YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED IN AND
JUST SAY GO BACK?
>> I'LL BE VERY CLEAR WITH YOU.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS.
I KNOW YOU DID INTERVIEWS MORE
THAN A DECADE AGO WHEN YOU
TALKED TO BREWER.
ONE BREWER WAS ARIZONA GOVERNOR,
PASSED LAWS THAT DID EXACTLY
THAT WHERE THEY WOULD SEND
PEOPLE BACK AND NOT ACCEPT
PEOPLE AND THE LAW THAT ARIZONA
PASSED WENT ALL THE WAY TO THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT.
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
SAID ARIZONA DOES NOT HAVE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT I USED TO BE AND SO I
FOLLOWED THE LAW AND THE LAW
THAT I'M GOING TO USE WILL BE
LEGAL IN WHICH TEXAS IS GOING TO
START ARRESTING EVERYBODY COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER, NOT JUST
ARRESTING THEM, BUT BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE AGGRAVATED
TRESPASS, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SPENDING HALF A YEAR IN JAIL IF
NOT A YEAR IN JAIL AS WELL AS
OTHER ACTIONS THAT I WILL BE
ANNOUNCING NEXT WEEK.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, I APPLAUD
ALL YOUR EFFORTS.
I KNOW YOU ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE OF YOUR STATE AND THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB IN SPITE
OF HAVING HANDCUFFS PUT ON YOU
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
GOOD LUCK IN YOUR